oh dude can we play that because if any
listeners are confused
all right no just go see money go just
so just go see money
money talks uh i wonder if we can play
jay i'll sing with chris let me see
are we allowed he starts touching
yo please dog
[Laughter]
i love him so much
that's so crazy i think they still love
him over in china chris tucker oh cause
he did russia yeah and rush out three
was kind of
uh what you say they still love him yeah
i think like he's popping over in china
like he has a very big chinese fan base
because of rush hour neither he was oh
yeah he was super skinny
i think he just oh i think he just
started like really getting into the
movies
now he
ice cube didn't want to pay him enough
then he was like i'm out did rush hour
well he also people forget he was in uh
this uh what not put fiction
he was in um oh fifth element elements
oh chris he's not that big anymore he
got big for a little while yeah he got
big and then he's back down again
i get it as far as like uh wait wait
wait wait wait
look at him and michael jordan why is he
yeah yeah he have legs like
yeah damn
damn me and mj that's crazy he was so
big so funny too he's still hilarious
hell yeah it's chris tucker right mm-hmm
come on man come on man my momma said
come here boy
mama i'll tell you what though him how
he uh
moved on from friday but then they
brought mike epps and mike
ebbs my gift not a bad second option not
a bad did you did you know how chris
ice cube found uh mike epps went to a
comedy club
and they did in l.a yeah which one uh
i don't know huh copy that so he finds
him in a comedy club
and and mike epps is killing it and then
meeting him back and i was like bro i
think i gotta roll for you
jesus and he goes to audition and mike
epps is killing it
so bad like chris i mean ice cube can't
keep a straight face
like yeah it's it's on youtube so uh was
that
mike eb's first movie first movie damn
yeah
and he just killed crush crush it dude i
tell you what
you've seen him live honey he's so funny
i saw him live he was like one of the
first like comedy shows i've ever been
to
man yes the beast like i got a i got a
cramp in my stomach from laughing
oh my god literally it made me cry tears
beastie beast
who was the first comic you saw live
yeah she was like dave chappelle
oh that's where what's on live in a
small
theater in denver oh hold on yeah filmer
i was uh
senior in high school oh [ __ ] you and
jay
no me and my boy wait what year did you
graduate uh 0-1
oh okay so that's right so he was
working on killing me softly
i think so yeah super beast though he
had the sesame street bit
yes yeah he was working on the okay i
gotta go softly yeah
my first comedy show i saw live was a
guy named david arnold
yeah yeah you know what i'm talking
about yeah then i then i saw the other
big one i saw
uh daniel tosh right we're like right
when he did
he always wanted to see daniel yeah it
was weird because i
i don't know it wasn't it wasn't great
it did like the crowd wasn't feeling it
it was it was a theater yeah i was in
the theater in denver
he's really he killed oh he's a monster
but for whatever reason the crowd just
wasn't vibing with him yeah well you
know
he goes pretty dark yeah he's hilarious
so funny yeah
it's been like my dream to see him live
yeah beast happy thoughts right
happy thoughts yeah he doesn't do any uh
i think he just you don't do any media
or anything no no he's nothing
nothing he's like why would i yeah he
does no interviews
nothing you know what i want to see live
no pun intended chappelle i want to see
her
hair uh harold boris hannibal bear and
embarrassment
i know right yeah what the [ __ ] i was
thinking about so special during
quarantine
during the course oh yeah i saw it that
wasn't that's that wasn't
in miami that wasn't it oh so i did you
watch it so i
opened for him that i got to tell you
this i like it so there was this one
time
he uh i think he's got he's got family
out in phoenix
uh-huh and so whenever he would come
through we would we would kick it
and we weren't and we were at this bar
almost two minutes right
we're at this bar chilling and michael
turner was there too
and these people kept looking and i'm
sitting next to hannibal and these
people kept looking
at how long ago is this was it famous
then yeah this was like 20
did he do baywatch 26 this was 2017
oh yeah he's fake yeah yeah so we're
sitting there and these people just keep
looking over at us
and but they specifically kept looking
at me and i'm like man
i think they think i'm hannibal and i'm
sitting right next to hannibal and the
only reason why i thought that was
because they just kept looking at me
now i had my glasses on and he didn't oh
well i was going to say
yeah this dude i think his friends are
like go
just go up and ask he's probably cool
dude walks up to me
and goes please you're hannibal burst
and i look up at him i was like
oh no then this girl runs up she's like
oh my god i love you on broad city gave
me a hug and [ __ ]
and then i was like no no i'm not
hannibal burris he's hannibal burst and
then he goes
don't let this man fool you
he's a cool cat though he's so goofy for
him
yeah open door he was funny oh he's so
funny he's so funny
he's so funny what's great he's worked
his ass off monster well you gotta
remember he started with schultz and uh
yeah norman and all the boys from
chicago
yeah he's great dude i like you i know
it's so funny i showed my dad a picture
of him
because i was like i was like dad
everyone keeps thinking i'm related to
or look like this guy
i was like does he look like anyone in
our family would you know or anything
like that
and my dad looked at him he goes oh my
god he thought he said he goes y'all
look just alive
similar but i'd say i'd say you're more
handsome
go to the one we had to give you yeah we
had to get yeah
she has more hands right there of course
yeah she looks he looks like her dad
yeah a guy yeah i didn't know he had one
he actually he
uh he had to get his teeth fixed he got
jumped
really he got jumped in chicago him and
his cousin that usually had happened
yeah he uh his teeth got
his teeth got [ __ ] up now remember he
was the one who actually leaked the news
on bill cosby he's the only one that got
this heat on
did he leak it or was it well he was the
one that really
brought it to him brought it to
attention because i think all comics
kind of knew like there's the
the hearsay and like everyone talked
about how kind of creepy is
yeah he's the one that really blew it up
yeah that's his bit it was funny though
i mean he did get a lot of flack
i wonder if bill cosby is calling the
shots behind the wall because he has a
lot of them
in prison they say they love him in
prison obviously he's bill cosby doug
how much time he got left
she got like well it's been like six
years he about to get out right it's
been six years ten years
he got three to ten years in prison
september three to ten years i bet he's
out and
[ __ ] i bet he gets out soon certainly
that's what i'm thinking as well
copy that that's his most recent mug
shot in person oh yeah i saw that
damn you know what if you hear some
people talk about this they think he's
innocent still
oh yeah yes there's still a campaign
some people think he's in it yeah when
when when
when it's like after like four or five
it's like it's like 60. i know how many
how many 60 you're lying wait 60 came
out man
yeah i think more than that it was more
than r kelly right
oh yeah okay
well r kelly we got video and [ __ ] you
there's nothing on bill it's all old
[ __ ]
sixty women zero
what if they that is insane i don't
wanna talk to also two instances of
alleged child sexual abuse
both involved 15 years what he's
probably not getting out
yeah two years if yeah 60.
damn all those years
60 women damn crazy do you think he's
living good in there
as good as you can and you're a legend
of like bill cosby i don't think he was
gonna [ __ ] with bill cosby
yeah nah he's keep calling the shots on
the yard he has to be as much i don't
think he's calling the shots i just
don't think anybody's [ __ ] with him
and i bet he's happy
i bet he's telling stories
he's a legend i'm sure there's some old
gangsters in there who love him and
he's got that's why he's not isolated so
he's just like chilling oh he's not
isolated that's what they said
i think so yeah so he's just apparently
he's crushed in there
yeah meaning like everyone loves them
irish they heard they love she'll ignite
in prison
uh is he getting out or did he get life
i think well i mean
he ran i don't know yeah he killed well
he ran killed a guy yeah
but they should knight killed a guy ran
him over on the set
of uh uh straight out of the competition
what a dumbass
28 years 28 years damn eligible for
parole in
2037.
well i'm sorry to just bring him over
but yeah
but they said he'd bring gifts to like
people on the yard he'd take care of him
put money on people books that's why
they love him so much
oh really yeah that's my homie i'm sure
he's protected in there too
yeah he's probably anyone's [ __ ] with
suge knight there's some tougher guys in
prison
but yeah but at the same time like with
his resources i think it's more
beneficial
yeah true to be on his good side yeah
maybe wait time out can you say
hannibal's name correctly now
no i had the t i'm sorry no i had the
team
what did i say whatever i don't know
what you said i don't know yeah
i was like surprised you caught it
because i was like i don't know where
it's going
he's like i'm the biggest fan
of horrible burrows
i said well you better learn to spell
his name what's that community horrible
bosses
[Laughter]
i love that guy you didn't you didn't
like his uh his new special
miami and i didn't like it it's too many
graphics and then it wasn't i didn't see
any crowd
lasers i didn't like it i mean but it
was different so i appreciate it it was
different
what did you think about it um i i mean
it was cool it was different
it was tough case came at the same time
as mark norman's march was so good
but hannibal's was just different it's
different than he's also
super famous now so it was like i think
sometimes we get super famous some of
the material it's hard to relate to
yeah i don't know he's a monster he's
you know two
he's almost two million i think that's
why eddie murphy said he kind of like
had to take a break take a break from
stand up because he was just so famous
i know yeah because your perspective is
so [ __ ] up when you're that famous
well kevin hart though
like just such like the characters he
did from
snl that's right that's why steve martin
stopped doing standing here this story
well steve martin was on one of the
biggest live tours of all time
and uh he would go out there and people
would be before he even got to punchline
people would yell it out and he's like
[ __ ] people
and then he said he was doing a show and
was going horrible great book
uh born standing up yeah i heard a story
i heard it's great
but he had a scene where a guitar would
come down
and whoever was doing it backstage
[ __ ] up the
guitar didn't come down and it was a
nightmare and everyone's just dying
laughing
and he was like oh my bad like got it
[ __ ] up everyone's just dying laughing
he's like
oh i gotta stop like they're not
laughing at my jokes anymore they're
like they're just laughing because i'm
here
yeah so he stopped doing stand up damn
quit he didn't like doing uh late shows
either you know like we do like
early show late show yeah he stopped he
didn't like doing late shows you'd only
do early
yep he would only do early him and i
think we get after a while
yeah it must be nice just do like one
giant theater show at like
seven then you're done yeah him and
martin short uh do a tour together
but it's music i like morning shows oh
it's music well i think it might be well
i shouldn't say that yeah it is they
were doing a music
well steve martin was doing a music
thing because i was gonna go see him
in uh i think him and martin were uh
they're heading north a little bit i
forget where but i was gonna go see him
mm-hmm
yeah he stopped doing late shows yeah
but but these shows can be fun
but it's a different perspective once
you get famous i agree with you but
think of kevin hart
but he's starting he talks about his
family though he just keeps talking
about family he also has writers
so that helps yeah those old school guys
didn't have that
a lot of them didn't well they couldn't
they could come back listen i'm not
saying that's why kevin hart's funny i'm
just saying that it helps
yeah because there's going to be
different those people that are giving
them point
pointers aren't crazy successful yet
okay
well you need your boys around you right
yeah yeah yeah you know his i think his
team is doing fine
for himself kevin hart fine well you
know what i'm saying like his
perspective is
insane it's like kanye going on rogan
everyone's like dude he's crazy it's
like
or he's just so [ __ ] famous his
reality is so [ __ ] up
it's just that's his perspective he's
not crazy i don't i don't think he's
clinically crazy
no everyone's telling that i think he
just a real smart guy but his
perspective of life is so
altered that he seems like an alien to
them he is bipolar
but we can he's also a narcissist the
biggest narcissist in the world
yeah like think about it dude he has a
billion dollars
he's married to kim kardashian has a
beautiful family has his own [ __ ]
shoe line
he's one of the most successful street
lions of all time and you gotta run for
president i put all that on my vision
you're not gonna win and you run for
president for what yeah so yeah so like
how
much fame do you need like yeah like
what's enough mm-hmm
you know no that makes sense i mean he
needs to talk somebody i watched it i
was like oh i was like oh this guy's
just like
the kind of stuff yeah i don't turn off
after 20 minutes oh you didn't give him
a second
i
i don't know i thought like you know
like when you try to explain like an
idea to somebody and they don't
necessarily get it but when you produce
it
it's it's brilliant everyone's like oh
there it is it's genius that's
i feel like that's how he is he doesn't
know how to relate explain what he's
trying to say to people but when he does
it yeah
you know it probably just like oh there
it is that's what he was trying to say
look at the yeezys yeah maybe you know
what i mean
that's a possibility i'm not saying like
hey this is what kanye is
you know what i mean like yeah you know
so don't add me but uh
um but but i think like he just you know
he understands it clearly to him it
makes so much sense in his mind yeah
but like when he gets to other people
they're just like so he's probably like
it probably makes him feel a little
crazy like how do you not get what i'm
saying how do you not get what i'm
saying
but i think he just has to produce some
type of result
to that's how i feel you know really
that's how i feel when i'm trying to do
a news
current event like we're saying
celebrity names
you know i it's a bit like everyone's
saying kanye is crazy i think if you're
that
famous like you got tom cruise on rogan
for
three hours tom cruise is so [ __ ]
famous some of the [ __ ] he says if he's
real like at least connie is not fake
at least he's giving you this crazy ass
idea you calling tc
fake though i mean yeah well have you
ever seen that scientology chess
did you see [ __ ] uh iron man on rogan
like you're not getting the true guy
they're actors so he can peel back those
layers like matthew mcconaughey it's
like
dude you're not that pop your energy
ain't that high though didn't you didn't
i heard this episode was great
yeah i dig it but it's like you're not
getting real [ __ ] with kanye at least
it's real
yeah didn't you tell me about how tom
cruise easy now
no i didn't tell you that copy that i
didn't tell you that stuff we said
targeting the green
don't come in here does it
i've never told you that
but i think if you get anyone that
famous you know like he hit the rock on
there if
he could just drop the whole tough guy
persona and talk about real [ __ ]
yeah i bet it's gonna be a little
[ __ ] crazy
nah i feel like the rock's pretty real
yeah i feel like he's pretty hot he
doesn't have a demeanor he just like
says i don't think he i
i mean he's such a polarizer figure that
i think he can just come off how he
looks like
if you like it you like if you don't you
don't i think he's the real that's real
to me now if he had vin diesel on talk
that [ __ ]
we all questioning but i think that's
real i think that's real vin diesel
and good morning i think i think i think
you've been fooled
wow you think he's i think i think
you're buying into it i i i a lot of it
like
if you think what you see on instagram
from the rock be like no i think he's a
real american buys ford for everybody
and
he just works out hard that's why he's
jacked i think you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
what what i didn't if you think he
posted biden
just because he actually cares about
politics we're not saying you're crazy
no we're saying if he's on rogan
right and we're are we getting are we
going to get the real the rock we're not
getting it
i'm not talking about i'm not talking
about instagram i'm talking about the
real interview he comes
but here's my thing for you how do you
know that you know the rock off what
awful wrestling and you think that's
real i like the brahmo bull
you know what i'm saying it's like like
we don't know the rock you don't know
the real
yeah my point is kanye's not playing a
role he's not playing up some persona
he's not doing any of that
he's such a narcissist he's being real
because he thinks that's what people
want to hit because
those other guys those other guys are
actors man it's all persona
narcissist is like he's so narcissistic
sociopath what
social media is it's a very fine line
bringing up with the definition of a
narcissist
i can give you a quick breakdown
sociopath like you don't feel any
remorse
about anything you do no and it's about
you everything's about you narcissists
they're just so
full of themselves and so egotistical
got it
taylor swift she's full of herself yeah
oh taylor swift
welcome to new york bro that's not even
welcome to new york listen to that song
carter again and holla at me
okay i will i'll report back click on
that for me what's the difference
between narcissist sociopath
narcissistic number one has a grandioso
sense of self-importance
exaggerates achievements and talents
that sound like anybody you know
wait hold on dreams of unlimited power
success brilliance beauty ideal love
lacks empathy or feelings requires
excessive
admiration believes he or she is special
and unique
and can be understood only by or should
be associated only with other special
and high status people sound like
anybody you know
uh i mean that's not like all of us
no
no i was just i was talking about the
last part which one the one they said
believe in herself
believes he is she is special unique and
understood only by yeah i think we all
kind of
[Music]
he is special and unique and can be
understood
only by or should only associate with
other special and high-status people i
didn't see that got it
yeah those people are going to read it i
apologize yeah you don't
you don't you don't you don't associate
with that no i don't know yeah
i don't know i just read the first it
was clickbait you want to jump to a
sociopath right now yeah yeah you know
what this is right social path gets
pretty dark
anti-social i mean there's a lot of
people out here like that though
yeah that's that's the grimy yeah you
know yeah it's very rare you find
genuine people it's called hollywood i
mean everybody's trying to be something
because no one knows sociopaths are more
manipulative yeah manipulation their ego
isn't always at stake
in fact they don't have any real
personality their ultimate con artist
can take on any persona that suits them
thus they may be harder to spot wow
because they're because they're not
trying to impress you or when your
approval
is a different agenda yeah instead of
bragging their conversation might center
on you rather than themselves
yeah so narcissist is it's only about
them like you ever been in conversation
we know people like yes where you're
talking and if you're talking about
something going on in your life
they're staring somewhere else oh yeah
they're like oh damn crazy and then once
it's about them they're all in oh 100 or
you i have people
used to be in my life where if it wasn't
about them dude
there's no conversation yeah and you
could be going through some heavy [ __ ]
or were they or were people that like
ask you a question that sets up because
they wanted to come back to them
yes you know what i'm talking about card
like what'd you do today
i went and then and then i was like well
i did yeah i'm like well pretty crazy
day
really yeah yeah oh okay yeah i hate
that [ __ ] yeah it's a bit just be real
be honest with yourself you know i know
that sounds
you know i know it comes from easier
said than done but
just read some self-help books how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son